sick of this whole cage situation i'm
busting loose
man that hurt yes and that hurt me as
well due to the fact that i feel pain as
any ordinary canine would you ain't
normal man you know when i first heard
the idea what kind of pets will your
favorite superheroes have i jumped at
the opportunity
what's going on
you're super strong when one has an
abundance of power they have a certain
duty to use that power to
sorry
you were saying something how much did
you have to drink
oh crypto has a false sense of reality
because of his relationship with the
biggest superhero on the planet you
think you're so great don't you super
dog i love the relationship between
crypto and ace smelling stuff is one of
the greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body i mean i
lick myself all the time well that
explains the breath kevin i've been one
of my best friends for almost a decade
now so you can feel the authenticity in
our relationship on screen there's a
nice little comedy see-saw that we're
able to provide because we've worked
with each other so much and i should
warn you i'm one eight bucks
and 7 8's chihuahua
they did a great job casting the movie
everyone has such different senses of
humor and personalities it's just really
fun to see it all come together what's
happening sweet cheeks
really really makes you laugh
crypto who's a good boy it's paradise
for an actor you're inside a room by
yourself and you're just having fun
if you want to create a really
unforgettable character you hire your
kevin harts your dwayne johnsons it's
just what you do
that's cold man this is a movie that you
can all watch together enjoy and laugh
at
there's huge fight scenes there's great
spectacle it's crazy how much work goes
into this it's really a good time and
full of heart ace deploy canine shield
what is okay now
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why could i have gotten a magic hammer
or something